walk through koth droplets that are
still vaulting through the air either on
a crowded street or on a beach florida
hi everyone i'm mark i'm founder of
disaster doc we help people all over the
world to better understand disasters so
they can protect themselves and others
so today I'd like to help you better
understand the co v19 pandemic and to
share with you a few tips for staying
well during social distancing and why
this is so critical and important for
all of us the first step to protecting
ourselves is understanding how Co V
infection occurs this virus needs to
float in a warm bath this warm bath is
actually body fluid and it needs this in
order to survive so it's more likely to
travel to you as in the form of a
droplet so people are said to be exposed
when they come in contact with the
droplet so where do these droplets come
from they come from inside infected
people's lungs people come in contact
with these droplets either by direct
exposure or indirect exposure but how do
we stop the pandemic we need to stop
people from touching and breathing these
droplets tip number one stay the F home
like the science shows avoiding
exposures is the single most effective
way to avoid infections and end this
pandemic even if you have no
consideration for your own health or
that of others
the longer that you decide to socialize
in public the longer every one of us
will have to shelter in place and wait
for this pandemic to end and if you do
need to go out avoid exposing yourself
some of us can't stay home right some of
us have to work in public and some of us
even work directly with the public so
what can we do to protect ourselves and
to protect our loved ones at home who
are depending upon us to not bring home
this infection we avoid those direct and
indirect exposures that I mentioned
earlier for a moment I want you to close
your eyes and picture this 6-foot bubble
around your body your skin is clean your
breath even your coffees virus-free
our bubbles change shape as we walk
through the air extending behind us a
little
as we move in the air and what our
bubbles cross each other we share the
same air and the same droplets so when
we share our 6-foot bubble with someone
else droplets from their coffee are more
likely to reach our lungs unless we try
to block it in some way think of the
world as being made up of three zones
the hot zone the warm zone and the cold
zone the cold zone is your home where
everyone is healthy and virus free it's
less work to keep your bubble clean and
virus free when you're in your cold zone
you don't have to worry so much about
touching your family or your face as
long as everyone stays healthy the water
zone is the world outside your door the
warm zone consists of those places
outside your home where it becomes more
likely that others may step inside or
perhaps even COFF into your six foot
bubble this could be your workplace it
could be standing in line at the grocery
store could be inside of an elevator
these are the places where we should
protect our bubble these are the places
we should also be respecting and staying
out of other people's bubbles so finally
there's a hot zone the huts are our
environments that by their very nature
cause people to come in contact with
each other to share bubbles or to even
touch these can occur at the cash
register they can occur during a coffin
the subway or the elevator or bus or a
taxi they can also occur when we
inadvertently walk through cough
droplets that are still vaulting through
the air either on a crowded street or on
a beach in these high-risk zones you
should protect your skin you should
protect your mouth your eyes and your
nose with the best barrier that you can
find when I return home I immediately
disinfect these things that I used in
the hot zone also including my credit
card in my cell phone right now I'm back
in my clean little bubble in my cold so
so mistake number one people are still
shaking hands two weeks ago I attended a
business meeting a public health meeting
where people were still shaking hands
and hugging touching elbows in some sort
of odd elbow wing dance simply increases
your likelihood not only looking like an
idiot but also being a spreader correct
me if I'm wrong but aren't we supposed
to be sneezing into these same elbows
that we're now sharing and touching each
other that doesn't make sense with me
how about this smile wink nod touch your
heart don't touch each other mistake
number two people aren't careful when
handling contaminated things like
sunglasses and face masks and cards and
phones and cigarettes and vapes I also
encourage you to avoid eating when
you're in the hot zone those things can
come directly into your mouth that way
so mistake number three people aren't
using masks I know that the Surgeon
General said that face masks are not
necessary for the general public I'm not
saying go out and purchase a mask in the
current market and please don't
I'd recommend any type of facial
covering to protect your eyes and mouth
and nose
even the handkerchief over your mouth is
better than receiving that full viral
load of a cough directly in your face
dr. julie gerber ting the former
director cdc has said that even the
t-shirt over your mouth and nose would
be better than nothing
now mistake number four people of
privilege are being insensitive to a
minority in today's world of pandemic
that people of privilege are those that
have their youth to protect them how can
we justify behavior that hurts the most
vulnerable we can't we are in a crisis
and if you can reach out you can
literally save the lives of vulnerable
populations by protecting them and
preventing them from ever contracting
this illness
and finally I just want to say it's been
a long scary road to get here and we're
not home yet but I can tell you that our
homes will return to normal this
pandemic will end and when it does we
will all have a deeper understanding of
ourselves and others we will have joined
together across parties and across
borders to fight a common threat we will
have learned the stories of the heroes
from the streets of Wuhan as well as
heard the songs of resilience sing from
the rooftops of Assisi join together in
a common bond
[Music]
you